good afternoon and welcome to this
special presentation of the voices in
leadership series at the Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health I extend a very
warm welcome to all of you here in the
audience and to the thousands of you who
are joining us online for the live
webcast of this session the voices in
leadership broadcasts are part of our
schools leadership education programs
and they offer an opportunity for
students and faculty to hear from very
high-profile leaders in a variety of
health-related areas and also to learn
from their experiences as they reflect
on their leadership experience and their
own careers these speakers are candid
about the decisions they have made along
the way and they share the lessons that
they have learned over the past five
years we have been fortunate to welcome
ministers of health leaders of
international and non-governmental
organizations u.s. officials members of
different Parliament's and this
broadcast are posted online after each
event so people can view them at their
convenience I encourage you to visit our
website and and you can view all of
these sessions I would like now to
invite dr. Atul Gawande to come up to
the podium many of knew of you know Atul
as a staff writer for The New Yorker
magazine where he has published very
many many very insightful health-related
pieces and also as the author of several
best-selling books including the recent
being mortal which tackles very
fundamental issues around the end of
life we're very proud that he's a
professor at our department of health
policy and management and that he is the
founder and leader of our regional labs
a joint venture with the Brigham and
Women's Hospital so we're delighted that
he could be here today and at all we'll
be introducing our very special guest
for this afternoon
well I am delighted to get to welcome
and be in discussion with Chelsea
Clinton Chelsea Clinton is the vice
chair of the Clinton Foundation where
she's been working alongside her parents
the President Bill Clinton and Secretary
Hillary Rodham Clinton to drive the
vision and the work of the foundation
she has had a focus on certain goals and
those have been especially around
improving global and domestic health
including with the Clinton health care
access initiative the Alliance for the
healthier for a healthier generation the
Clinton health matters initiative in a
variety of other programs she's had a
lifelong interest in public health and
in global issues she has gotten her
Doctorate from Oxford in international
relations she got a master's in public
health from Columbia's melman's School
of Public Health where she's been also
teaching graduate school courses around
global health and governance
she has been exercising major leadership
in a major should leave leadership role
in areas that are very close to us at
the Harvard School of Public Health and
I look forward to talking to her about
that work she's been doing first however
she's going to talk about the
Foundation's work to make a difference
in the lives of the world's most
vulnerable people and following her
remarks we'll have a chance for a short
discussion including questions that
students have submitted and so now my
pleasure to welcome Chelsea Clinton
well thank you a tool Thank You Dean for
welcoming me thank you to Betty Johnson
for all of her stewardship of this event
and ensuring that we all got here on
time and in the right places thank you
to everyone at the School of Public
Health in the broader Harvard community
who's made this event possible today I
also would like to thank dr. null for
all of her work on behalf of cancer
survivors here and around the world we
were just talking about hopefully more
work that we can do together through the
Clinton Global Initiative this year and
in years ahead I am particularly
grateful to be in conversation with a
tool because he is something of a hero
in my family as as he may not be aware I
think my father deserves some credit for
his tremendous book sales that the Dean
talked about although I know you have a
more recent book out my father continues
to hawk shamelessly the checklist
manifesto it's certainly required
reading in my house and I wouldn't be
surprised if here as well and all of the
chuckles I think validate why it is so
important that all of us think more
about the systems that we too often take
for granted I want to spend most of the
time that we have today in conversation
with a tool based on the questions that
he would ask and and those that you have
submitted but before we move to that
conversation I do want to talk a little
bit about the work of the Clinton Health
Access Initiative and the Clinton
Foundation in global health and in
health here at home in the United States
in 2002 when my father left the White
House he knew that he are in 2001 when
he left by 2002 he knew that he wanted
to do something around hiv/aids but he
didn't know sort of what that something
would be he didn't know how he would be
uniquely positioned given the work that
he had done as president given the
people that he knew given his I think
remarkable ability to distill a
challenge to understand kind of when a
system needs to be fixed or when a
system needs to be better defined and
created
how to apply all of that to the
challenge of AIDS 2002 seems like many
eons ago now the Global Fund had just
opened its doors
PEPFAR wasn't even yet a twinkle and
President Bush's eyes there were only
200,000 people in the developing world
on ARV treatment the vast majority of
those lived in Thailand and Brazil
countries that could afford to have
their own generic manufacturers of ARVs
and in which the countries had
sufficient resources to either subsidize
or outright purchase a RVs for their
hiv-positive citizens and so this was
the environment in which my father
traveled with Nelson Mandela to the
Barcelona International AIDS Conference
in 2002 he was determined to do
something he didn't quite know kind of
what would be most impactful the world
was starting to pay attention more
resources were being marshaled but not
yet to real effect in too many people's
lives around the world
and while at the AIDS conference he was
approached by dr. Denzel Douglas who
then was the prime minister of st. Kitts
and Nevis in the Caribbean as dr.
Douglass explained to my father st.
Kitts and Nevis didn't have a real
challenge that was an impediment to
accessing treatment and care for so many
people around the world it didn't have a
stigma problem but it did have a
significant money problem and a systems
problem and so we asked for my father's
help to better negotiate with the
generic drug manufacturers at least in
Brazil just over the Caribbean to the
South for not only st. Kitts and Nevis
but for the Caribbean writ large because
even the Bahamas the wealthiest nation
relatively speaking in the Caribbean
wasn't able to provide drugs for its
hiv-positive population and my father
thought yes I can figure out how to do
this and so that was the genesis for the
Clinton Health Access Initiative and
really for the market shaping work that
is driven much of the Clinton
Foundation's work around the world not
only in health but in agriculture in
combating climate change and fighting
childhood obesity here at home so in
when the average ARV price was upwards
of $10,000 the Clinton Health Access
Initiative is a nascent entity began to
negotiate with multiple parts of the
system and for the first time really
defining a system recognizing that kind
of the challenge of what had been
characterized as a high price low volume
market shouldn't have to persist as such
given the resources coming online from
the Global Fund the tragedy of the
increasingly recognized AIDS challenge
around the world and so today as I know
many of you are aware the average cost
of antiretroviral treatment per person
per year is between one and two hundred
dollars in some countries it's even less
and of the more than ten million people
that are on treatment in the developing
world 8.2 million of them access
treatment through more than 70
agreements that the Clinton Foundation
in the Clinton Health Access Initiative
helped to negotiate now more than four
million of those acquired treatment
through PEPFAR dollars so that makes me
proud not just as a daughter but also as
an American taxpayer you laugh but I
mean that quite sincerely I think it
says something about our values as a
country that we continue to make access
to treatment a national priority that
market shaping work try then translated
into helping negotiate a more than 50
percent decrease in the price of the
pentavalent vaccine massively expanding
the purchasing power of Gavi UNICEF and
others a more than forty percent price
reduction in injectable long-lasting
reversible contraceptives ensuring that
more women have more agency over the
choices that we make for ourselves and
our families around the world and that
paradigm then got translated through the
Alliance for a healthier generation
which Atul mentioned the partnership
between the Clinton Foundation and the
American Heart Association the genesis
of which was my father's own hearts care
that's the euphemism that we use and my
family for his almost cataclysmic likely
to have been fatal heart attack that
thankfully was prevented when he did the
right thing had chest pains called his
doctor and had a quadruple bypass
surgery
at the end of 2004 at the beginning of
2005 he called the American Heart
Association he said well what can I do
he said we've been doing this work
around AIDS across the world do you
think any of that would have utility
here if we thought about kind of heart
health
you can we help drive down the price for
treatment could I be the poster boy for
prevention like what can I do and the
American Heart Association said sure all
of that would be great but what we
really need your help on is combating
childhood obesity and while there's a
lot of awareness now that childhood
obesity is a significant challenge in
our country that wasn't as well
syndicated or socialized at the
beginning of 2005 when my father began
working on childhood obesity and he took
the same principles that had helped to
animate Chai's work and applied them to
the Alliance's work working to build
consortiums of school districts to
better effectively purchase healthier
options for school lunches working with
beverage manufacturers to ensure that
they could still ship the same quantity
at the same price of beverages to
schools to sell in vending machines but
moving away from full calorie sodas to
waters into flavored waters doing things
that individually may not have such an
impact but collectively coalescing again
thinking about sort of the food system
in which kids live and work and play and
go to school as a way in which to really
combat and ameliorate the childhood
obesity challenge and increasingly this
is recognized as not just a challenge
for those of us who care about public
health but for Americans who care about
any concern that's facing our country in
2013 the Joint Chiefs of Staff declared
childhood obesity a national security
crisis in 2014 the New York City Fire
Department and Police Department
acknowledged that they were unable to
recruit sufficient numbers of new
officers because too many were failing
the physical fitness exams the National
Council of Economic Advisers I said the
childhood obesity poses the risk of an
economic tsunami almost irregardless of
what Nets out and the various concerns
around our health
system reform and so thankfully that's
given real momentum and agency to this
work because ultimately and I think a
tool and I will talk about kind of how
we assess success at the foundation or
in our family we're always trying to
work ourselves out of a job
and so because increasingly childhood
obesity is recognized and not just a
moral imperative that we need to correct
but a security and economic imperative
school districts increasingly are able
to find their own funds to better
purchase food increasingly the Defense
Department is giving resources to
schools that are on or near military
bases so that they can do the same
increasingly other foundations locally
whether it's in Miami or litora core
Northern California are helping to
support school districts to do similar
work and so that means that we're able
to take that work and do it elsewhere
that to us is ultimately what success
looks like when the governments that we
help negotiate with the generic drug
manufacturers no longer need us to help
negotiate the next generation of drug
agreements of the more than 70 countries
that we helped originate their
negotiations more than 40 have now done
the second and third negotiations on
their own that to us is real success
when there's a transfer of skills
wherewithal and systematic understanding
such that in the best sense we're no
longer needed and so I hope that we can
talk more about our work in public
health around the world or our work with
school districts and more broadly here
in the United States including the
newest unlikely partner with the
Alliance for their generation McDonald's
you laugh but a majority of American
kids this is true eat at least one meal
a month and a McDonald's so if we're
gonna solve the childhood obesity
challenge in our country we truly have
to continue to go to where kids eat and
McDonald's committed at the Clinton
Global Initiative meeting in 2014 to
move away from french fries and Happy
Meals towards fruit or vegetables to no
longer include sodas and happy
but instead include milk or water or in
some markets fruit juices they've almost
entirely made good on that commitment
here in the United States and it's one
that they're working on achieving around
the world because sadly childhood
obesity is no longer just an American
challenge so hopefully we can talk a
little bit about how we think of success
how we think of needing to engage often
unlikely but necessary partners in
tackling any public health challenge or
other challenge where we believe we are
uniquely positioned to make a difference
and also how we think about saying no
because for those of us that care so
much about public health I think so
often we think we have to say yes but
sometimes the smartest thing we can do
is to say no to the first option so that
we better can say yes to the second
option where we're more well-positioned
and equipped to make a difference so
thank you for welcoming me thank you for
being interested in the work of the
Clinton Health Access Initiative and the
Clinton Foundation and I look forward to
talking to a tool I guess about whatever
he wants to talk about although I've
kind of put a few mental markers in that
I hope he will permit so thank you all
very much
that was great and I think what was
great about it is it gives a picture for
people of just how deeply embedded you
are in leadership in global health and
public health in the United States you
have well I read a profile of you and a
bunch of profiles and I think the most
interesting thing that was said was that
of the three Clintons you are the one
who is most hands-on at the foundation
and it described your direction as more
data and outcome driven arising from
some of what you were hinting at you
know the desire to try to prioritize and
to have clarity about metrics of
outcomes very comforting for a public
health community here that likes to
think about the cost-effectiveness of
what we're doing and push in that
direction so if the key struggle is
prioritization do you want to influence
that at the foundation how you know what
are the levers that a young leader has
walking into a big foundation well thank
you at all I think there were lots of
questions there and I'll try to answer
them in in a way that that makes sense
in an overall arc and I'll do that in a
in a couple of ways I think that the
fact that the foundation has been
successful in some of the ways that I
outlined actually increases the burden
on us to kind of continue to prove the
validity of our model but also to
syndicate the validity of our model you
know I think that it is now terrific
that we take for granted that there are
lots of market discontinuities that
remain low-hanging fruit in various
health commodities around the world
there's lots of work that's happening
for example now on various testing
economics you're trying to change not
only kind of HIV or rapid infant
diagnostic testing economics but
increasingly to change the economics
around malaria and tuberculosis testing
and otherwise you know we are engaged in
some of that work but most of that work
we are not engaged in and I think that
that is is terrific
and so part of what I've done at the
foundation is to try to help us be more
open-source to try to be more
transparent with our partners whether
our funding partners or our programmatic
partners kind of whether that's through
the Clinton Health Access Initiative or
through the Alliance for elder
generation or otherwise with kind of
what we've done that we really think has
worked kind of at a very granular and
practical level so that others can learn
more quickly from our successes and also
our stumbles and then I think we have an
obligation to think about logical
extensions of our work that may not be
immediately apparent so again thinking
about the Alliance
I'm deeply passionate and I talked about
this actually when I was here in 2013
the juvenile justice system there are 53
some 1000 young men and women who every
night sleep in a juvenile justice
facility in the United States
disproportionately they are young men of
color disproportionately they have
significant health challenges they are
depending on the state at least as
likely if not more likely to be
struggling with obesity than the non
juvenile population and because we've
seen real success in the districts where
we do a lot of deep work on childhood
obesity where at least the childhood
obesity rates have plateaued if they
aren't yet declining but again today do
we have to sort of stop the the upward
trajectory before we can reverse it I
really believe that we had a moral
imperative to try to translate the work
of the Alliance into the juvenile
justice system and so a couple of years
ago we started working with California
and Arkansas similarly through sort of
hands on technical assistance paradigm
helping the facilities and the systems
be smarter purchases of food helping
figure out how ways to get physical
activity back into the juvenile justice
systems in a way that the systems would
feel comfortable but would really be
kind of authentically useful for the
young men and women living in those
facilities and we partnered with Emory
as our evaluative partner and the pilots
of those programs showed what we hoped
would show an increase in health
literacy
an increase in the kind of confidence of
the young men and women and the
facilities to feel like they knew how to
make healthier choices for themselves at
least in terms of diet and exercise and
then one hopes that those healthier
choices helped ladder up to other
healthier choices in their lives and
we're looking to extend those programs
across the country so that's a little
bit how we think of success and sort of
a macro sense and also how we think of
kind of what our next step
responsibilities are to extend the
programs that we believe are working
well so here embedded in what you're
saying you know the Clinton Foundation
the global the Clinton Global Initiative
a particular kind of famous for its
pledges and I hear you saying also we
want to be famous for our outcomes and
the successful outcomes and you're
describing some pretty sharp metrics not
easy to hit that that are going into
that that your sounds like you're
pushing towards as you prioritize what
the foundation tackles and what it does
not tackle how do you use either data or
is it your gut as a family about what
you want to go towards you know Prison
work or heart disease in the personal
case of the president's what what drives
that set of decisions about what you
will do and what you'll won't do it's a
great questions one that I think about
obsessively yeah I do I think about it
obsessively and you know we we always
try to start from kind of where are we
disproportionately at least likely to be
able to have a positive impact either
because of market shaping work that
we've done already or because of our
kind of school-based network or because
of work that my father and mother may
have done historically and if someone
asks us to do something because I think
another important point to make is that
we only work at the invitation of
national or local governments or
whatever the pre-existing institution is
so for example for chai we only work
with the invitation of national
governments for the Alliance for
healthier generation we only work
through the school district so we're now
in hundreds of school districts across
the country we work with more than 16
and a half kind of million kids lives
everyday through the new 27 832 last
checked schools but all of those school
districts have asked us to help enhance
their health and wellness position and
so when we think about kind of what more
we can do and what we say yes to we
start with sort of where we are and so
an example thinking about a doctor naal
as we were asked a few years ago through
the Clinton Health Access Initiative to
help a country where we've done a lot of
work on on AIDS and tuberculosis in
particular to help design their cervical
cancer program but we didn't know
anything about cervical cancer and we
didn't know anything about the sort of
kind of primary secondary and tertiary
care systems that were in place around
cancer already in that country or kind
of would need to be in place and how to
get from A to B and so we said no we
made suggestions of other partners that
we thought were more well equipped to
help that country kind of transition to
the vision that it was just starting to
define and I think that was the right
choice for us so you having a
disproportionate likelihood to say yes
or even to affirmatively go out and do
things that are kind of you know
extensions from a technical standpoint
or a programmatic standpoint from work
we're doing already or where we have
previous experience and and to be very
judicious about saying no even when
partners that we have deep and
productive working relationships with
asked us to do something that we don't
think we're the best to do one of the
questions came from the students of the
knowledge you gained from your Masters
of Public Health what was the most
important for your future career
statistics
because well I think it cycles back to
my obsession with data I had I done a
lot of work in economics and I was
really comfortable kind of with
economics yet you're still laughing but
I think that means that a lot of you
agree with me secretly even if you are
not as comfortable being as obvious
lynard like um you can program its data
yeah I love Stata and and access and all
sorts of other programs and I think
that's actually been really useful for
me because it enables me to absorb
information more quickly from kind of
more sources it enables me to kind of
mentally sift through it and and catalog
it and I think that you you know in a
world in which there are so many demands
on all of our times and now that I'm a
mother and I'm always trying to be even
more efficient in my work to maximize my
time with our daughter Charlotte and I
just am so grateful to all of my kind of
bio stats and the additional statistics
that I I took at mailman your PhD and
now your course at mailman that you're
teaching on global health is about
global health and governance so what I'm
wondering is what do you think is the
key thing people don't understand about
the link between goal health and
governance and especially what what does
it mean that governance connects to
global health and global health outcomes
to you goodness well again I think lots
of questions I think you know one of the
challenges is that so often we focus
only on what's in front of us I think
that's inevitable kind of for all of us
and so you know understanding kind of
the ways in which the world works sort
of that I would argue what has happened
over the last year with Ebola was not
inevitable kind of in a kind of
philosophical or theoretical sense but
it almost was inevitable given the
system in which it happened kind of
given the current state of kind of
global health governance as it is kind
of currently constituted kind of from
the whu-oh at a kind of global and
regional and national level
gonna given the fact that we continue to
be more responsive than prescriptive and
how we kind of think about fragile state
health environments and so for me when I
kind of think about or teach about kind
of global health governance it's
understanding the cascade of events in
which kind of any kind of one narrative
occurs whether it's kind of Ebola or the
case of AIDS and you're trying to not
take for granted how important inertia
is kind of in those narratives kind of
given the state of the institutions from
a formal multilateral standpoint but
also kind of from a donor standpoint out
of a developing country standpoint a
kind of foundation standpoint and and
yet then thinking kind of well what is
the ideal and how do we get from here to
there in a practical political sense
well I'll give you an example that I
feel like I struggle with all the time
we have a number of teams here at the
school who are involved in trying to
improve maternal and child health and a
recent studies showing that you know
when you measure what matters it's
things like do they have enough access
to facilities for delivery do you have
the right medications do you have the
right personnel all those kinds of
things but the strongest predictor that
you would have any of those things is
corruption and how to tackle and what to
even do about places where there's deep
corruption and you know your choices are
well we we don't work in those which
should we not work in those environments
if we're gonna work in those
environments how do you engage in
corrupt governments so have you started
to have some sense of what you do and
don't do to even move the ball forward
in a space and also recognizing how of
what happens you here in the United
States also impacts kind of the ways in
which organizations or even kind of
individuals are able to to work in areas
across the world so as a practical
example you the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act here in the United States
historically has not been applied
to foundations to NGOs to even kind of
domestic funding of you and agencies
that work in often imperfect
environments but there are various
states Attorney General's there have
been people who have advocated for you
know still serving Attorney General
Holder that the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act be extended to NGOs
foundations to not only those of us that
engaged in sort of direct service work
but you know also theoretically the
Gates Foundation which is the behemoth
funder in in global health around the
world
which would completely change this
argument because right now the
values-based conversation is you know am
i comfortable being in a situation where
I might be you know perpetuating kind of
a long term dysfunction kind of to
facilitate sort of short term gains that
you can justify thinking well if they're
healthier people they'll grow up
hopefully to be healthier voters and
maybe you know in the next generation
they're going to vote out the kind of in
you know those who've been engaged in
the endemic corruption that entirely
shifts if the legal burden on whether
it's the Clinton Health Access
Initiative or the Gates Foundation or
kind of smaller NGOs just dedicated to
helping you know protect and advance
maternal health whether it's in kind of
Cambodia or Costa Rica are going to be
examined through the lens of the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act in which if you
have any knowledge of any corruption in
any place that you are doing business
your assets are frozen and you're unable
to do your work that is that is a
fundamental governance question and I
would argue it's one that for those of
us that care about global health we
should be engaged in those debates at
the state and the national level because
often I think those of us that think
about public health don't realize how
kind of political or legal conversations
happening that ostensibly are quite
disconnected what we do can have real
implications for if we're even able to
do the work that so many of us feel
called to do it's not an idea it heard
it be
really radical even to use the commuting
part of the Clinton Foundation to bring
people and NGOs around what are we
really doing about corruption that's I
think a fascinating indication of where
you're potentially able to push things
in your leadership role one area that
you have really embraced recently is
about the role of girls and women and
their status around the world and you're
applying this very outcome driven notion
to it can you tell us a little bit more
about this campaign you're launching so
I'm deeply passionate about everything
around girls and women and I didn't know
that I could be more passionate about
this until I became a mother and until I
had a daughter it's somewhat I heard huh
yes I think that also something that
clearly has resonance and you in 1995
when my mom went to the Fourth World
Conference on women in Beijing and
declared that women's rights are human
rights and human rights are women's
rights something that shouldn't have
been in Cindy airy but at the time was
actually censored on Chinese television
so clearly was deeply threatening at
least in the place where she was
speaking and was certainly not taken for
granted as a principle much less as a
kind of motivating kind of design force
and how we think about development
programming and aid and she really began
her advocacy on behalf of women and
girls whether in maternal health or
enabling women to equally participate in
the work force around the world and kind
of that thread of her life again
thinking about where are we
disproportionately able to make a
difference kind of for whatever reason
kind of led my mother and me when she
decided to join the Clint Foundation to
really think about well kind of what can
we do to continue to advance what at
times can feel a Sisyphean task but one
that we believe is not only morally the
right thing to do but strategically and
economically the smart thing for us to
do to ensure the full and equal
participation for women and girls we
realized again two tools point around
convening power that we could likely
convene unlikely partners and so we
believe the no ceilings report that we
launched a few weeks ago is the most
comprehensive data set ever
the status for rights and participation
for women and girls around the world
partly because we worked with
traditional data partners
I'm sure datasets that many of you are
familiar with kind of from the World
Bank various UN agencies but also less
traditional data partners like Facebook
whose Facebook has the largest female
population in the world more than 700
million active female users on Facebook
so trying to understand the ways in
which women are using technology to
sometimes circumvent or ameliorate the
ceilings that they still face in their
own lives and then putting all of it
online in an open-source searchable kind
of easily usable downloadable you can
download it into Stata as well as Excel
and other kind of formats because we
hope that kind of it will have validity
and utility to people you know sitting
in this room but also to kind of young
people around the world to try to help
better articulate kind of what they want
to see and kind of to better make the
case to see that for women and girls and
I think that's true here in the United
States I mean one thing that I kind of
again just to say to a belieber some
extent because it continues to surprise
every kind of meeting I'm in or every
fora in which I'm speaking is that the
Unites States is one of only nine
countries in the world to not have paid
maternity leave for mothers of infants
right it's surprising to I think many of
you and if it's surprising to many of
you who clearly have a public health
bias or otherwise we wouldn't all be in
this room together kind of imagine how
surprising it is to people who don't
have a public health kind of bias or
vocational calling and and the company
that the United States is in is Suriname
and then largely South Pacific small
island nation states you know countries
that have significantly fewer resources
than we have here and and to me that's a
real value judgment that we continue to
make as a country that we continue to
not invest in ensuring that mothers have
those crucial kind of early moments and
even months to feed and to bond with
their children and so for my mother and
for me the new
ceilings work you know hopefully helps
not only kind of assess where we are but
illuminate kind of where we need to go
because of what progress has been made
you know in 1995 the United States
wasn't one of nine it was one of
literally dozens so the world has moved
beyond us and I think that we need to
make the right choice for our future to
catch up do do you have another example
of a measure that you feel is moving or
that is moveable that brings a concrete
sense of what status improvement really
means well I think another one that I
think generally people find surprising
where we haven't improved on a global
level is a workforce budget ease excuse
me workforce participation so in 1995
55% of women over the age of 16 were
either in school or working in 2013 55
percent of women around the world 16 or
older were either in school or working
and in the United States it's not much
better it's just shy of 58% and you know
this is actually fundamentally a systems
question right I mean how do we ensure
that we shift expectations around what
is acceptable for women how do we ensure
that kind of policies in the United
States where kind of a lack of paid
maternity leave is one of the last
barriers kind of his overcome but also
they're more than a hundred countries
around the world where there still is
legalized discrimination against women
in the workforce where women can be
denied jobs or it's legal to pay women
less there are a number of countries
where there's still restrictions on
women's movement a number of countries
where there's restrictions on whether a
woman can open a bank account or get a
loan without having a male family member
cosign so we have a pretty clear sense
now in a way that we didn't 20 years ago
of what the barriers are and we have a
lot of data about what happens when
those barriers are removed but we are so
far from being where we need to go and
so you know at the Clinton Foundation
and particularly through CGI using our
convening
our trying to convene real conversations
that hopefully have a lot of kind of
attendant peer pressure to help whether
it's government's move to where it's
clearly in their best interest to move
or kind of getting foundations and
others to continue to dedicate resources
to often sort of unsexy subjects or
sometimes politically sensitive subjects
to help amplify the public pressure kind
of within countries to help ensure that
every every girl can grow up and be
whatever she wants to be the students
had a lot of questions directed towards
the idea of how a young person can lead
and you have been trying to do that how
do you think a young person leads an
older generation where they may not want
to go especially when a couple that
might be your parents you know how do
you how do you exert leadership within a
foundation that's been so defined by
your parents and and what do you think
the lessons are for young people about
being able to do that because in some
way we're all defined by the older
generation completely I think well I'll
answer the question first about my
family and then answer the broader
question about about the foundation
because I think they're they're
different but you ask them both and I'm
happy to talk about each you know within
my family I'm really grateful that we
have had kind of a conversation about
what we think the challenges the
opportunities the solutions are whether
today or in the future literally my
whole life and the first thing I learned
to read was the newspaper one of my
earliest memories truly is during the
1986 gubernatorial election which my
father was running against a man named
Frank white who represented the darkest
part of Arkansas's past he was an
unapologetic segregationist he was just
determined to kind of drag Arkansas back
to the dark days and he was my father's
Republican opponent for re-election my
father was running in 1986 and I guess
the benefit of having three family
members is that you have
kind of two candidates in a moderator
like built-in to the breakfast table or
the dinner table and so we would have
these kind of fierce debates in which my
parents would kind of force or empower
me depending on your perspective
to play my father to play Frank white
and to play the moderator and I think
that was hugely useful training not only
for my debating skills later in life but
also for being comfortable talking to my
parents on an equal level and that they
always treated me with the expectation
of having my own opinion and I think
that was a gift they gave me that I
didn't quite understand how profound
that was until I became a mother of
realizing that they didn't only listen
to me they expected me to have a point
of view they expected to have the data
and the evidence to defend that point of
view and they expected me to be able to
do that you know in under 60 seconds in
the debate woman so I think that that
that has has enabled me to kind of be
comfortable when I historically this is
in the public domain disagreed with my
parents about big issues like gay
marriage a number of years ago until
they kind of came to a place where they
support equal marriage rights in our
country and two things even kind of
within the foundation which are often
questions of prioritization not so much
sort of what we should be doing but
maybe what we should be doing first or
kind of how we should be organizing
ourselves to do something so that's sort
of the family-based answer so I guess
the takeaway is that I will be kind of
forcing Charlotte to have lots of
debates as soon as she's able to talk
and then at the foundation I think you
know it's it's a few things I have a
great amount of respect for all that my
father has done that had nothing to do
with my mother and me that he really
kind of was the genesis of and kind of
continues to be the driving force for
and have lots of humility and respect
for the people who have helped him do
that work and continue to help him do
that work and there are parts of the
foundation and the clinic access
initiative that still very much are his
Bali with where my mother and I are
much more in a supportive posture in the
same way there are parts of the
foundation that my mother and I lead or
that I have more kind of leadership in
and she has more leadership than
respectively and so I think that is a
healthy ecosystem we talk about
everything we kind of develop priorities
at a macro level but there's also very
clear areas where kind of one of us is
more of not just the public face but
really kind of the driving day-to-day
animation of the work as she's
contemplating running for president it's
bringing a lot more scrutiny to the
Clinton Foundation how do you keep the
foundation and yourself effective going
into this you know chaotic future that
it's coming well that's your resuming a
chaotic future
I don't know I can't comment on the
future or the chaos part I can certainly
kind of hope that it will be less
chaotic but expect that it will be quite
chaotic I think we just continue to do
our work I mean I realize that might
sound like a girl-scout answer but I
really believe that I mean I believe
that if we continue to do our work if we
continue to have real results we will
continue to be able to work with the
partners that we have had such
productive impact with so far whether on
the kind of government side whether on
the local community school district side
and of whether on the funding side
whether on the evaluative partners side
I think we can continue to do our work
and we can continue to prove our results
we'll be able to continue to do our work
well you've been incredibly impressive
and forthright about what you think and
what you're doing I think I'll ask my
last question which is we've had a
chance to talk about a wide variety of
things what do you think for the
students are the two to three key
takeaways you might mention about
leadership I think one it's important to
have a really honest assessment about
what each of us are good at and not good
at I think it's important to have a real
honest assessment about what we are most
passionate about or most angry about I
think kind of anger and interpersonal
relationships is not
very useful I think anger is a
motivating force about kind of injustice
in the world it's incredibly useful to
help us figure out kind of what each of
us want to focus on and I think being
comfortable kind of asking for feedback
from those around us who we really
respect in terms of kind of what they've
already done either in advance of us or
along side us because I think we are
either always growing or we really are
kind of falling flat and catherine the
great said that you know states and
people are the same either we're growing
or rotting I don't think we're quite
rotting
I think that's yeah the Dean is laughing
that's a bit extreme but I do think each
of us wants to continue to be more
efficient and effective and I think that
we get there by continuing to have a
clearer sense of what we're good at not
kind of what we're passionate about and
not and and I've drawing on our cohort
or our mentors to help us define each of
those in a way that it drives us forward
well just over a year ago we had our
hundredth anniversary and you were the
recipient of our next generation award
and I can see exactly why Thank You
Chelsea for this and creating such a
significant impact thank you very much
we'll ask you to stay with us stay tuned
for the next generation award
presentation for the successor to
Chelsea
thank you at all Thank You Chelsea for
this fascinating conversation
I think you've illuminated the way
people can work together and have that
unique combination that Josie was
talking about at the end of
introspection passion and commitment and
and even that channeling of anger for
all of those things that we feel we
cannot tolerate in the world as Adam
mentioned you got a great example of why
Chelsea Clinton was the recipient of the
first next-generation award these are
what was instituted last year last
academic year when we were celebrating
our first 100 years of life as as as the
School of Public Health and the idea was
that along with Centennial medals that
would give in to President Bill Clinton
alumni Gro Harlem Brundtland and former
alumnus and faculty member Jim Kim we
wanted also to look forward to the next
100 years and therefore institute an
award that would identify outstanding
leaders under the age of 40 who have
already shown a light on the world a
positive light for the commitment to
health as a fundamental human right and
a commitment to achieving health for all
around the world those of you who were
here to attend that memorable
celebration in October of 2013 will
remember Joseph passionate words back
then and it really made me realize what
a great idea this next generation award
was and and the notion that we should
continue that because it is this
generation and the new generations to
come who will be here for our second and
third Centennial's so we are truly
delighted the Chelsea is here with us
and we've asked her to present the next
next generation award to a very inspired
inspirational and distinguished
individual and I am delighted that Blake
Mycoskie has
accepted to receive this award
Blake is the founder and she chief shoe
giver that's his official title of Tom's
he's also the creator of one-for-one
which is really an innovative
transformative business model to help a
person in need for every product that
gets purchased so please join me first
in watching a very brief video
highlighting Blake's
accomplishments thanks to Blake Mycoskie
a simple idea has grown into a global
movement and with that idea the company
he founded TOMS shoes has provided over
35 million pairs of shoes to children
since 2006 as if that were not enough
Tom's eyewear has restored sight to over
275 thousand people by providing
prescription glasses sight saving
surgery and medical treatment Tom's
roasting company has helped provide more
than 100,000 weeks of safe water in
seven countries since 2014 and now Tom's
bag collection is funding training for
skilled birth attendants and
distributing birth kits to help women
safely deliver their babies Tom's has
had such an impressive impact thanks to
the one for one business model Blake has
created that model ensures that a person
in need is helped with every product
purchased the Harvard th Chan School of
Public Health is honored to present its
2015 next generation Award to Blake
Mycoskie for his leadership and
commitment to improving lives by
providing shoes sight water and safer
birth and services to
from Nepal to Kentucky
Chelsea will you step up to the podium
to present the award to Blake Thank You
Dean if it were not quite so cold I
would be wearing my TOMS shoes so I just
have to say that I will make that up to
Blake when it gets a little bit warmer
because spring at some point has to
finally arrive I think there are so many
remarkable things about what Blake has
created some of what you saw in the
video but arguably equally remarkable is
how now so many of us take for granted
that this is a viable business model
that the one-for-one model that Blake
pioneered is a viable approach to
achieving social good and to having a
real impact in the world and if
imitation is the greatest form of
flattery then Blake is flattered many
times over and I wouldn't be surprised
if some of you are thinking about of
your own ideas
under this one for one aegis I couldn't
really imagine the world without TOMS
shoes partly because of all the work
that you saw highlighted in the video
but also partly because of what a
remarkable partner Blake and Tom's has
been with the Clinton Foundation when my
father asked Blake if he would open a
shoe factory in Haiti he just said yes I
don't know if he kind of realized he
could have said no he could have said no
my father still would have been equally
kind of an enthusiast and fan of Blake
and Tom's but thankfully Blake said yes
and you know a place that it was deeply
kind of connected to my family's heart
my parents took their honeymoon in Haiti
and where my father has been working to
improve good governance to help remedy
so much of kind of what a tool talked
about kind of at the institutional level
in Haiti clearly having a vibrant
economy is part of ensuring that Haiti
is on a path to success and tom has kind
of been part of that solution I know
only will be even more so in the time
ahead and when my mother and I asked
Blake if he would partner with us on our
work around saving Africa's elephants
at current rates of poaching the African
elephant will disappear and a little bit
more than a decade Blake and his wife
Heather said absolutely and we've been
thrilled by the results of that effort
which have provided vitally crucial
funds to the Wildlife Conservation
Society's African elephant preservation
efforts across the continent again an
issue that may seem sort of disconnected
from health and development but actually
is intimately connected to both because
of the groups that are now engaged in
poaching across the continent such as
al-shabaab and Boko Haram and so TOMS
shoes is not only kind of at the
forefront of ensuring that more people
have the ability to walk to school or to
play that have that more mothers have
the confidence to deliver their children
in a safe and healthy manner but also
helping to change the shape of the
Haitian economy to help protect the
African elephant and I have no doubt
doing so much more that so many of us
will never even hear of so please join
me in congratulating Blake on his next
generation award
oh yeah
Thank You Chelsea Thank You Dean thank
you everyone for having me here it's
it's it's a little bit surreal to be
standing in front of a group of people
who are committed their lives to public
health and improving it because you know
that journey really started with me just
nine years ago and when the journey
started I didn't really even know that
the journey was beginning when I when I
was down in Argentina nine years ago I
was there on vacation and I happened to
be noticing that there were many
children running around without shoes
and on streets and in environments where
there was glass and stones and different
things that could hurt their feet and I
didn't think much about it but
throughout my vacation towards the end
of it I happened to have a chance
meeting with a few women in a cafe that
were doing volunteer work in Argentina
and they specifically were doing
something they were calling a shoe drive
and when I asked him about what the shoe
drive was all about they explained to me
that just two hours outside of Buenos
Aires this wonderful city there were
children
barefoot which I'd already seen but
specifically these children were not
being able to go to school because in
their town there was a school uniform
requirement and the uniform required a
pair of shoes a pair of closed-toe shoes
many of these kids had flip-flops but
that would not do for the case of
getting them to school and so these
women had take it upon themselves and
worked with the local nonprofit in
Argentina to go around and collect
slightly used shoes from wealthy
families in Buenos Aires to give to
these children and I was just so you
know blown away by the initiative these
women had taken and I you know was
asking a bunch of questions and
throughout the conversation they said to
me they said well look we're going in a
couple days if you would like to come
with us you're more than happy and so I
said great and at this point in my life
I had never done anything like this my
family had been charitable you know I've
seen that growing up but I'd never been
in the field or on the ground
I'd like this being provided and so I
really didn't know what to expect but
when we went into this village and
Lowe's ple tonus a couple days later and
we showed up with a u-haul full of shoes
I saw these kids and these families so
incredibly excited I mean you would have
thought it was Christmas day and we were
Santa Claus I mean these kids were
running around putting their new shoes
on playing their families were happy and
and and I and I understood that they
were not just happy because of the shoes
but they were more happy about what the
shoes represented and that was that
someone believed in them someone cared
about them and that they would have the
shoes needed for the school uniform that
was in for the school year that was
getting ready to start and I remember
going home that evening to the place I
was staying on my vacation and talking
to my friend Alejo who was actually
trying to give me polo lessons of all
things and and I said I totally Laiho
about the experience and and he and he
said you know that they thought it was
really great what they're doing but he
asked me a question he said Blake what's
gonna happen for the next pair of shoes
cuz you're you know these volunteers you
know two of whom live in the UK one's
going back to the u.s. who's gonna give
him their next pair and and that
question I didn't have an answer for and
I remember going to bed that night
thinking about you know that could that
question and and and and the next
morning is when I woke up and over a cup
of coffee and writing in my journal had
the idea for Tom's and this idea that
instead of asking for donations or
depending on charity to help keep these
children and shoes what about starting a
business a for-profit company where
every time we sell a pair of shoes we
give a pair away and that small idea I
took back to California started selling
shoes out of my apartment and then as
the video said we've now given over 35
million shoes in the last nine years and
thank you
and and and I want to tell a quick story
I hope I have enough time I already got
a time card but I don't get this
opportunity very much to talk about
public health and I think this is a
really important story for me and for
and I it's also a plea for the smart
minds and here to help us with this is
about a year and a half after I started
Tom's I was I was giving a talk actually
at a local church and and a woman came
out to me afterwards and showed me these
pictures of feet there were so grotesque
and so deformed that it blew my mind
it honestly looked like something you'd
see and Ripley's Believe It or Not these
were human beings that had feet that
looked like elephants and and she
explained to me that in Ethiopia there
was a disease called Puerto Kony OSIS
and basically it was a silica in the
soil that would get into the lymphatic
system and totally destroy the the feet
from the legs down and that the women
and children and men that contracted
this were totally shunned from society
that many of them were locked up and
hidden if there were women many times
they would commit suicide and this was
all happening because they didn't have
the proper shoes and sanitation and she
pleaded with me to go to Ethiopia now at
this point I had never even you know you
know been anywhere near Ethiopia but
within a month
I went on a plane and I saw this
firsthand and I must say I thought I was
gonna go into a clinic and see like four
cases five cases but the first time I
walked into a protic oneitis clinic in
Ethiopia I saw hundreds and hundreds of
people with this disease and and I
couldn't believe it and that's when I
knew a year and a half later that I was
getting into public health and that you
know and that shoes not only could help
children go to school but they could
present prevent diseases like pota Kony
osis or hookworm which we use our shoes
to prevent a lot in Central America and
since then we found that there are very
simple treatments that can take someone
who has pota Kony osis and get their
feet back to normal in it as well as the
prevention so you know my wife and I on
our foundation are investing heavily in
this and this protocol uses clinics as
well as continuing to provide shoes in
Ethiopia and other places where our
shoes can prevent this type of disease
so so why you might not
immediately think of footwear as a
preventer of disease it very much is so
in many parts of the world and and as
the video shown you know we have been so
excited about using the one-for-one
model to address other needs in the
world whether it's maternal health which
we just recently started doing with the
safe birth kits and the training of
birth attendants through the sale of
bags to our eye care
cataract surgeries etc so it has been an
incredible blessing for us you go to
take this one for one model from shoes
and to be able to help and in so many
other ways so it really is an honor to
to take and to accept this award and to
be recognized by the public health
community in something that is so
passionate that we are so passionate
about whether we knew we were getting
into that nine years ago or not and so I
just closed was saying that you know the
the simple mission of Tom's is to use
business to improve lives that is what
we do and that is what we talked a lot
about how we do it is our one-for-one
model every time we sell a product it is
it comes with a promise that when you
buy that product it will be used to help
someone in need but why we do it and the
why is what is is really simple
we simply care about one another and I
think that everyone in the room here
that's exactly why you're studying
public health or you're engaged in
public health it's why Chelsea and the
Clinton Foundation has so much done so
much it's a real simple desire to care
for one another and so I accept this
award today from you know everyone at
Toms worked so hard otherwise I wouldn't
be standing up here but also on behalf
of everyone that just simply cares about
one another so thank you very much
Thank You Blake what you do is public
health so thank you for for for this
common sight what I'm an amazing and
remarkable story and to show that
everything in life is interconnected
I remember that 2008 Clinton Global
Initiative meeting where I was honored
by President Clinton with the global
citizen the Clinton Global citizens
award and that at that meeting I got my
first pair of TOMS shoes because Tom's
had been invited into the to the Clinton
Global Initiative precisely because of
the fantastic example of what you've
just heard it's been really a remarkable
morning
we've been fortunate to have Chelsea
Clinton and Blake Mycoskie to talk with
us today share their enormous insights
these are really remarkable individuals
who have claimed the mantle of
leadership for the next generation of
global health champions in dedicating
themselves to discuss they stand
alongside so many esteemed individuals
including our own students around alumni
and our own faculty who are working for
affordable quality health care for all
for a life that enhances the
opportunities of every human being and
for a global understanding that health
is truly our only hope for a shared
destiny I thank you all of you for
joining us today I think our two honored
guests and I hope we all go out of this
room and out of the webcast that
millions are proud of our thousands are
following with the inspiration that the
next generation provides to all of us
thank you very much
you